[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا كما يعني نتابع بالصوره ظلام
تام بهذه المنطقه نحن نتحدث عن محيط
القياده العامه للجيش وبالتالي انقطاع
للكهرباء هناك هذا الانقطاع دائما يترافق
مع المواجهات الكثيفه التي تكون طبعا
دائره بين كل من الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني بالساعات الماضيه منذ بدء الصراع
الانقطاع للكهرباء داخل العاصمه كان متقطع
يعني يذهب ويعود
وتيره تكون مع وتيره تصاعد حده الاشتباكات
حتى الساعه الاشتباكات ما زالت دائره
وحدتها ووطيره عاليه جدا كما نسمع
انفجارات
واستخدام للاسلحه الثقيله في محيط القياده
العامه وفي الخرطوم بالرغم من
موافقه الطرفين على هدنه لم يلتزم بها حتى
الساعه فلنستمع لصوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات